D
TO THESE HECKLERS, I WOULD SAY
THEIR PROTEST WAS QUITE
EFFECTIVE.
SOMEONE WHO IS MENTIONED IN
THOSE VIDEOS IS TULSI GABBARD,
AND SHE JOINS US IN OUR.
WHAT HAPPENED TO AOC?
DO YOU SEE THAT SAME KIND KIND
OF HEAT ON THE STREET WHEN YOU
GO OUT AND ABOUT, ABOUT THE
UKRAINE WAR?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO
HER OR WHAT SHE BELIEVES IN, BUT
I HOPE EVERYONE WAS PAYING
ATTENTION TO WHAT THOSE TWO
YOUNG MEN WERE SAYING AND PAYING
ATTENTION TO THE PAIN AND
ANGUISH AND THE FEAR AND THE
CONCERN THAT THEY ARE EXPRESSING
TO THEIR REPRESENTATIVE IN
CONGRESS.
THE FACT THAT SHE WAS SO
DISMISSIVE OF THEM POINTS TO THE
BIGGER PROBLEM IN WASHINGTON,
ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS WHY I
LEFT THIS DEMOCRATIC PARTY OF
TODAY, IS BECAUSE THEY HAVE
BECOME THE PARTY OF WAR HAWKS.
WE ARE LITERALLY SITTING ON THE
PRECIPICE OF NUCLEAR DISASTER.
YOU HEAR THESE YOUNG MEN SAYING,
NOTHING ELSE MATTERS IF WE ARE
ALL DESTROYED IN A NUCLEAR WAR
THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
DEMOCRATIC LEADERS IN CONGRESS
HAVE LED US INTO, AND THEY ARE
COMPLETELY FAILING IN THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY.
THE PRESIDENT'S FOREMOST
RESPONSIBILITY, TO KEEP US SAFE.
TO KEEP US FREE.
>> Jesse: ARE THERE ANY
DEMOCRATS THAT COME TO MIND
RIGHT NOW THAT ARE ASKING TOUGH
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE WAR IN
UKRAINE?
MOSTLY THOSE QUESTIONS COME FROM
THE RIGHT, WHAT HAPPENED ON THE
LEFT?
>> NOT A SINGLE.
YOU REMEMBER THAT $40 BILLION
FUNDING PACKAGE THAT WENT TO
UKRAINE, THE VERY BIG ONE IN THE
BEGINNING, THERE HAVE OBVIOUSLY
BEEN MANY SINCE, BUT IN THAT
ONE, THERE WAS NOT A SINGLE
DEMOCRAT IN THE HOUSE OR THE
SENATE THAT VOTED AGAINST IT.
NOT A SINGLE ONE.
I BELIEVE THERE WAS A TOTAL OF
66 REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE AND
SENATE, NO DEMOCRATS.
THEY HAVE BEEN ABSENTLY SILENT.
THESE PEOPLE ARE RIGHT.
WHERE ARE THE SO-CALLED
PROGRESSIVES?
WHERE ARE THE PIECE CHAMPIONS,
THE AOCS, THE BERNIES, ALL OF
THE PEOPLE WHO CLAIM TO BE
REPRESENTING THIS MOVEMENT, THEY
ARE ABSOLUTELY SILENT ON THE
ONES LEADING US INTO A NUCLEAR
WAR.
>> Jesse: THE PROTESTERS, YOU
DO NOT REALLY SEE A LOT OF
PROTESTERS ON THE STREET ABOUT
THE UKRAINE SITUATION.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT IS?
>> I THINK BECAUSE THERE ARE A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA WHO ARE USING THE SAME
PRO-WAR TALKING POINTS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS USING AND
NOT DOING THEIR JOB IN RAISING
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW
OUR TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE BEING
USED ON WHAT ARE THE COSTS AND
CONSEQUENCES TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE FOR THESE WAR HAWKS WHO
ARE LEADING US INTO
WORLD WAR III?
>> Jesse: YOU SPOKE RECENTLY
ABOUT SOMETHING, MAYBE IT HAD
SOMETHING TO DO WITH YOUR MOVE
AWAY FROM THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
I WANT TO PLAY SOME OF THAT FOR
THE AUDIENCE AND YOU CAN
EXPLAIN.
>> WHAT HAPPENS IN OUR SOCIETY
WHEN WE HAVE PEOPLE IN THE
HIGHEST POSITIONS OF POWER, WHO
DENY THE EXISTENCE OF OBJECTIVE
TRUTH?
WHAT HAPPENS IS THEN THERE IS NO
SUCH THING AS TRUTH.
THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS
REALITY.
TRUTH BECOMES WHATEVER THE
PEOPLE IN POWER AT ANY GIVEN
MOMENT WANT IT TO BE.
>> Jesse: TELL US A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT.
>> HERE KNOW, WE HAVE SO MANY OF
THESE CONCERNS.
THE ISSUE I WAS TALKING ABOUT
WAS TITLE IX AND THE FACT THE
SO-CALLED WOKE LEADERS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY DENY THE TRUTH
OF A BIOLOGICAL DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN MEN AND WOMEN.
WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY A HUGE ISSUE
IN AND OF ITSELF, BUT THE
UNDERLYING ONE IS EVEN MORE
CONCERNING, WHICH IS WHEN WE
HAVE PEOPLE IN POWER WHO DENY
THAT THERE IS SUCH A THING AS
TRUTH, THEN THERE ARE NO
BOUNDARIES TO HOW FAR THEY WILL
GO.
THE TRUTH BECOMES WHATEVER THEY
WANT IT TO BE ON ANY GIVEN DAY,
AND THEY HAVE -- AS YOU TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER, THEY HAVE THE
POWER OF THE LAW AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT ENTITIES THAT AT
THEY ARE WEAPONIZING ON
POLITICIZING AGAINST THOSE WHO
REFUSE TO COMPLY WITH WHATEVER
THE EDICT OF THE DAY IS COMING
THAT IS A DANGEROUS THING.
>> AND IT IS DANGEROUS WHEN YOU
LOOK BACK AT HISTORY.
WE NOTICED A DIFFERENT
HAIRSTYLE, VERY PRESIDENTIAL
LOOKING.
I'M NOT TRYING TO READ INTO
ANYTHING.
>> I WAS JUST TRYING TO DRESS
UP, IT WAS A FANCY EVENT.
>> Jesse: THERE IT IS.
LOOK AT THAT HAIR.